au québec les nouveaux propriétaires
d'immeubles sont protégés par la
garantie légale lorsqu'il y as
découverte de vice caché
la clause de garantie légale était
inscrite dans le contrat d'achat
et même s'il n'y est pas elle s'applique
quand même à moins d'une exclusion
parmi les plus fréquents vices cachés
déclaré on parle de problèmes liés aux
fondations au soleil des anomalies
découlant de la toiture des
infiltrations d'eau également avec nous
pour en parler la notaire yasmine
bensalem bonsoir alors légalement c'est
quoi vices cachés
bonne question un vice caché c'est un
problème qui malheureusement découvert
par un acheteur après l'achat ce qui est
important de retenir c'est que tout
problème n'est pas nécessairement un
vice caché non premièrement la
protection du vice caché ma provient de
ce qu'on appelle la garantie de qualité
et cette garantie là c'est ce qu'on
appelle une garantie légale c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'a pas besoin d'être écrit dans
le contrat comme vous venez de le
mentionner elle vient de part du fait de
la loi
elle peut être exclue si elle n'est pas
exclue la garantie légale de qualité
protège contre les vices cachés vices
cachés est un problème qui a une
définition en disant trois éléments
importants premièrement c'est un
problème qui existait qui prit exister
l'achat dont qui existait au moment de
la vente de l'immeuble le fardeau de
faire cette preuve là bas ça revient à
l'acheteur donc si on retrouve un
problème deux semaines après l'achat
vous ce sera dépendamment de la nature
du problème ça sera relativement facile
de prouver tout prix visitez l'achat oui
mais si on découvre un problème huit ans
après avoir acheté la propriété
ça sera beaucoup ça dépend encore de la
nature du problème
ouais alors deuxième donc ça doit prix
existait l'achat deuxièmement ça doit
être un vice caché le nom le dit un
problème caché et non connus de
l'acheteur donc qui dit vices cachés dit
un problème qui n'a pas été déclaré par
le vendeur maintenant il ya des il ya
des rumeurs qui courent que j'aimerais
adresser on dit le vendeur de bonne foi
qui n'a pas déclaré parce qu'il n'était
pas au courant lui-même et est exempt de
protéger des vices cachés c'est pas le
cas c'est pas vrai donc malheureusement
la loi dû trancher d'un côté ou de
l'autre a été tranché comme ça le
vendeur de bonne foi qu'il n'a pas
déclaré parce qu'il ne le savait pas
lui-même est quand même responsable
et quand on dit un vice caché et non
connus de l'acheteur n'ont connu de
l'ats
ça ça touche à la notion de l'acheteur
prudent et diligent
c'est quoi un acheteur prudent et
diligent c'est au minimum un acheteur
qui qui a fait une inspection visuelle
qui a visité la propriété qui est rentré
dans toutes les pièces qui a regardé en
haut en bas
parce que si le problème qui ressort par
la suite était apparent l'onu que
l'acheteur qui a visité trop vite ne l'a
pas vu c'est plus un vice caché au
québec comment fonctionne la garantie
légale alors la garantie légale
c'est une garantie qu'il sort de la loi
garantit l'égal donc c'est dans le code
civil du québec
la garantie légale quand on regarde la
loi et qu'on louvre elle elle fournit de
protection à l'acheteur la garantie du
droit de propriété et la garantie de
qualité
la garantie du droit de propriété c'est
le vendeur qui s'engage à vendre un bien
qui libre de toute charge tout ce
hypothèques qui est conforme à la
réglementation de zonage qui est libre
d'empiétement qui n'empiète pas non plus
la garantie de qualité la deuxième
partie la garantie légale c'est les
fameux vices cachés au québec dans la
plupart des promesses d'achat lorsque
l'acheteur et le vendeur font une
promesse d'achat avant de passer chez le
notaire
il est écrit que le vendeur s'engage à
fournir la garantie légale
ouais même si ce n'était pas écrit c'est
quand même ça s'applique quand même
parce que c'est prévu par la loi
donc à moins que ça soit expressément
exclue exclu par le vendeur l'acheteur
est toujours protégé alors on découvre
un vice caché
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est quoi les
recours bonne question alors
premièrement il faut s'assurer qu'on est
vraiment présence d'un réel vice caché
quelque chose peut sembler être un vice
caché mais ne pas l'être
un vice caché un problème qui était
effectivement caché qu'ils n'étaient pas
relatés par le vendeur mais qui découle
par exemple de l'usure normale d'une
propriété ce n'est pas un disque riche
mais si on est vraiment réellement
présence d'un vice caché
première étape très importante alizée le
vendeur par écrit qu'il faut se laisser
une trace écrite
il faut donner un délai raisonnable aux
vendeurs pour nous répondre faut donner
accès à la propriété au vendeur s'il
veut venir constater le problème de ses
yeux après cet avis écrit qu'on envoie
aux vendeurs s'ils acceptent de
collaborer de coopérer avec nous pas
tant mieux parfait tout va bien mais
sinon la prochaine étape moi ce que je
conseillerai ces deux conseils c'est
d'aller chercher conseil auprès d'un
avocat qui est spécialisée en la matière
parce que l'avocat va vraiment nous
donner l'heure juste sur non seulement
le le concept de vices cachés mais
également l'efficacité de notre recours
parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir un
vice caché d'être protégés grâce à la 46
légal mais notre recours est peut-être
très faible affaibli par le temps si ça
fait trop longtemps qu'on a acheté la
propriété ou la nature du problème donc
s'asseoir avec un avocat après ça si le
vendeur ne veut pas collaborer ça peut
devenir compliqué si plusieurs acheteurs
de propriétés au fil du temps également
effectivement il est possible d'exclure
la garantie légale lors d'un achat de
plus en plus populaire d'ailleurs
effectivement il ya ça s'explique alors
c'est une bonne c'est une bonne question
je vous dirais que par exemple si on
regarde les chiffres de 2012 versys 2016
pour les propriétés unifamiliales est
lié à une augmentation d'environ 50% de
l'exclusion de la garantie légale donc
entre 2012 et 2016 50% plus de vendeurs
ont exclu cette garantie 6 mois comment
je l'expliqué une théorie ça se révèle
le vieillissement de propriété les
propriétés sont de plus en plus vieille
le vieillissement de la population
également les gens veulent acheter la
paix d'esprit ils achètent la paix
d'esprit en excluant la garantie légale
je dis bien acheter parce que ça a un
coût quand on exclut la garantie légale
bain et il faut s'attendre à revendre la
propriété à un prix un peu moindre ça se
négocie à un acheteur qui achètent une
maison avec et sans garantie légale ne
va pas payer le même prix
ça prend combien de temps à régler un
dossier de vices cachés généralement
c'est ça dépend ça dépendra des ponts du
problème de la nature du problème ça
dépend à savoir est ce que les acheteurs
les vendeurs collaborent ou est-ce que
ça doit se rendre en cours
on peut parler de quelques semaines ça
peut être une question d'envoyer la vie
et aux vendeurs et le vendeur qui se
montre collabora collaborateurs ça peut
également se rendre en cours et puis là
on parle de quelques années et les
problèmes les plus fréquents c'est quoi
les fondations je voudrais les
fondations le solage les infiltrations
d'eau les problèmes liés au toit et la
moisissure la fameuse moisissures qui se
cache derrière les carreaux de la salle
de bain par exemple mais je voudrais
c'est les problèmes de fondations et de
solages qui sont les plus importants et
qui ont le plus haut taux de réussite en
cours alors oui c'est à dire huilé les
cas qu'ils se rendent devant un juge
un acheteur poursuit un vendeur pour un
problème de solages de fondations peu
près 50 % de ces cas obtiennent gain de
cause donc l'acheteur gagne son parcours
bonne chance
yasmeen bensalah merci beaucoup pour ses
explications ce soir